All right, welcome back.
Uh, I guess to myself, I'm back from Los Angeles.
I was on the Joe Rogan experience, one of
the world
biggest podcasts and youtube shows thanks
to Ben Dickson who filled in for me on sort
of short notice.
I mean it came, the Joe Rogan thing came together
pretty quickly.
I didn't even know that I was going to be
going to Los Angeles this week until the day
I believe it was that I was leaving on the
end of May break, which had been planned a
long time in advance.
So thanks to everybody who understands that
this was a big opportunity and I didn't intend
to immediately leave the show again.
So quickly after that, that brief break at
the end of May.
Oh, I also, I guess should thank all the trolls
for those nice messages leading up to the
interview.
David, you're going to bomb.
I can't wait to see Joe Rogan wipe the floor
with you.
You're going to embarrass yourself and all
of that stuff.
And the funny thing sort of is that when someone
sends a message like that, I actually wonder
if that person has never seen Rogan's show
or maybe has never seen my show because Rogan
has long form conversations with people, uh,
and owning or whatever is not really his thing.
I mean sometimes people do end up getting
exposed on his show as we pointed out, like
when Candice Owens or Dave Rubin go on there
or a Ben Shapiro goes on and says things that
don't make any sense.
But in any case I think it went really well
overall.
Um, I'm very self critical and in watching
it back after the fact, I don't think I handled
every aspect of the two plus hour conversation
as well as I would have wanted or maybe would
have if I had known in advance exactly what
the topics would be.
But that's the whole thing.
It's sort of an unplanned, informal, a long
form conversation.
And I know that I'm a huge self critic.
Many areas for improvement would have liked
to have been more clear in some areas, but
it was really a great opportunity for the
show.
It's already had a nice impact on the show.
Nice boost on Youtube, nice boost on podcast
subscribers, modest paid membership boost.
Although the thing about that is it takes
a while to convert a new viewer to a member,
since you don't immediately become a paid
member of a show, as soon as you hear about
it, most people don't anyway.
You hear about a show, then you watch it or
listen to it for awhile, and then some portion
of those people later become paid members.
So my, my hope is that in the next four to
12 weeks we'll convert a lot of that new audience
into paid subscribers and that'll be a really
great thing.
Um, also had a great dinner with destiny and
Sohn piker and my manager who all of whom
are out in Los Angeles.
There are some pictures on my Instagram from
that.
Uh, I was on another show while in La called
exploring minds with Michelle Carol, who's
an actress who also now has an interview show.
And I had about an hour conversation with
her.
It hasn't been published yet.
I think it will be pretty soon.
And I posted a picture from that behind the
scenes picture of Michelle and, uh, have me
on the Instagram account.
So check it out.
Overall, huge, huge win in the battle of ideas.
There were moments on the Rogan show where
Joe and I disagreed and I think those were
some of the best moments and it was fine and
it was not awkward and it was as respectful
as I imagined that it would be.
A, we talked about what constitutes a homophobic
slur in the context of Youtube's terms of
service, in terms of conditions, how to figure
out whether a company is liberal or conservative.
And we had disagreements and uh, it was, it
was absolutely great to have them and I hope
that it was productive in a sense for the
audience.
So, hi to everyone who has learned about this
show over the last three days.
Sorry, I guess to everybody who was waiting
for my appearance on Joe Rogan to go so poorly,
to be such an embarrassment to us, just such
a shameful face plant that it would decimate
the David Pakman show.
Um, I apologize if that's what you were expecting.
Onward and upward to more things and expansion
and more announcements coming soon.
Um, I did unfortunately have to mute hundreds
of people on Twitter after these appearances
because of the amount of just vitriolic trolling.
But my new approaches, I don't even think
about engaging with the nonsense on Twitter
or social media.
I see it, I mute it.
I don't have to think about it again.
And I strongly, strongly advise other people
in the audience to do the same thing.
Uh, unfortunately some of the people in the
audience are the ones doing the trolling and
so they probably won't take that advice.
But if you're a good faith actor on social
media, I'm telling you, I am doing much better
in terms of everything, productivity, focus,
uh, concentrating on the right things over
the noise.
Uh, since I have just started this policy
of no engagement with trolls, mute them, don't
think about them again.
Uh, that's, that's my advice to you.